for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions for how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy
previously we mentioned that a protein
would be digested into a bunch of amino
acids and taken up from the intestinal
lumen into the blood and eventually
taking to the liver so what happens to
them when they get to the liver well we
need to get their carbon skeleton so we
have to remove the nitrogen right the
ammonium ion to give what's called of
course they call carbon skeleton and
we're going to get that via
transamination okay now the
transamination the general reaction is
that we start off with an alpha amino
acid and this could be any amino acid
and we'll call this alpha amino acid
number one and we'll also start with an
alpha keto acid and that alpha keto acid
is specifically alpha ketoglutarate okay
now what's going to happen here is that
we're going to take the Alpha amino
acids amino group and alpha hydrogen and
basically remove them from this amino
acid and tack them on here at the alpha
carbon of alpha ketoglutarate and
basically what's going to happen is that
the the portion of this portion of the
Alpha amino acid and this portion of the
alpha keto acid alpha ketoglutarate
specifically are going to sort of trade
spots and so what's going to happen is
that if this alpha amino acid loses that
amino group and alpha hydrogen it
becomes this alpha keto acid right
instead of having the amino group in
alpha hydrogen there now there's just a
ketone right making it an alpha keto
acid so alpha amino acid number one
became alpha keto acid number one now
when that happened where did the actual
amino group go well the amino group in
alpha hydrogen went here onto alpha
ketoglutarate and when that happens that
turns that alpha ketoglutarate into
glutamate which is specifically an alpha
amino acid so that that pink arrow there
is showing that this alpha amino acid
number one becomes alpha keto acid
number one
and alpha-keto acid number two the alpha
ketoglutarate becomes alpha amino acid
number two which is glutamate
specifically so this is called a
transamination reaction and is catalyzed
by an enzyme called an amino transferase
or a transaminase and it's often named
the amino transferase often named for
the starting amino acid so for example
if we have alanine here at the bottom
this is our starting amino acid it's
going to be turned into its alpha keto
acid which is specifically pyruvate and
this is going to be catalyzed by an
amino transferase specifically alanine
aminotransferase right so it's an amino
transferase named for the starting amino
acid which of course in this case in
this example is alanine now this is this
general reaction appears often depicted
like this where it just shows the
starting amino acid and the carbon
skeleton or the alpha keto acid the
results and it shows the Alpha q rate
like this becoming glutamate all right
it's not explicitly showing the
structure it's just to save space
because it's understood what's going on
here when we have alpha ketoglutarate
going due to glutamate the question
might be though is what happened to the
Alpha amino group and the Alpha hydrogen
here where did they go I don't see them
whoa it's not explicitly shown but the
amino group and the Alpha hydrogen
attached to alpha ketoglutarate I was
transferred over there to produce
glutamate it's just not explicitly drawn
or shown okay doesn't mean that it
didn't happen okay so the net result of
a transamination reaction is basically
that the amino group right the amino
group oops
amino group right the NH four plus group
is transferred to alpha ketoglutarate
from the starting amino acid to produce
glutamate and be starting amino acid
ends up being its carbon skeleton
which was is the form we need it to be
in order for us to oxidize it for energy
okay now this amino transferase or
transamination reaction requires a
cofactor that's often abbreviated as PLP
that PLP is short for Paradoxal
phosphate Paradoxal phosphate there okay
and I didn't show it here but it's right
there okay so Paradoxal phosphate is a
cofactor that is important for
transamination reactions in fact let's
talk a little bit more about it paradox
with phosphate PLP it is the coenzyme
for transamination reactions and it's
actually it comes from pyridoxine
pyridoxine which is specifically vitamin
b6 okay so vitamin b6 pyridoxine looks
like this and pirate off so far
looks like this is what paradox of
phosphate looks like so the difference
really is that instead of having a no H
up here it has so that o H it has the
phosphate group so that is
phosphorylated there and instead of
having the alcohol here it has an
aldehyde and that's actually the reason
for the name the name change right
pirate Doc's al Paradoxal things that
end in al that is an indicator doesn't
aldehyde there and of course that
phosphate group makes it paradoxical
phosphate PLP so what happens during the
course of the reaction is that paradox
will phosphate will actually grab the NH
4 plus right the the amino group from
the amino acid number one that you start
with it'll grab it from amino acid
number one and then we'll carry it and
become paradox amine phosphate and then
again during again during the course of
the reaction that amino group is given
up by that paradox amine phosphate to
alpha P to glue to rate to make
glutamate which regenerates Paradoxal
phosphate in the form that we we started
with
okay so at this point we've removed the
NH four plus from the amino acid and we
put it on to alpha ketoglutarate to make
glutamate and we've got the carbon
skeleton now what happens that's what
we'll find out in the next with you how
if ever do is helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying